so I'll make you guys how you doing back
for another chatting cars with my good
friend dr. Lawrence Brown and when you
narrow it down and you come down to the
two religions dr. Brown
you have Christianity and Islam these
are as the other day we were refuting
the common argument that people say well
all religions make the claim that
they're the truth and really when you
when you and and then the absolute
religions when you narrow it down we
narrowed it down to really Christianity
and Islam the proselytizing religions
that call people to them when you come
down to these two the true the ones that
claim to be monotheistic religions will
exclude Judaism because they're not
really calling people to Judaism to be a
Jew it's more of the chosen people but
when you come down to these two now what
is the main difference between the two
if someone says okay I'm going to just
get go through Jesus to get my salvation
rather than Islam going directly to God
I mean first of all I have to say
obviously there are a lot more religions
out there than just Christianity and
Islam
however the the main discussion at this
point is between those two religions and
the way I explained it is it's just it's
like what we're doing right now and
driving down the road if we if we just
pull over the car right now and stop we
didn't get to the destination well
that's kind of how it is with the chain
of Revelation if you read the Old
Testament the New Testament and the
Quran you get an impression that there's
a continuity in this chain of Revelation
because there are a lot of similarities
now it's just a cop-out to say 1:1
copied from the other there are
historical reasons which are basically
proven that it's not possible for one to
be copied from the other and you can
visit those arguments if you're
interested in my books but but the point
just being that like what we're doing
now driving down the road if you stop
before you get where you're going you
know you haven't reached your
destination it's the same thing with the
continuity in the chain of Revelation if
you if you stop with the Prophet before
you get to the final prophet well your
destination is this paradise right and
if you are disregarded and choosing to
willfully disregard the final prophet
that's on you the thing that I find
frustrating about this is that when you
talk to Christians they you know they
often criticize the Jews for not not
getting on board to Christianity I mean
you know keep in mind Jesus was a Jew he
was called rabbi Jesus okay Christianity
was not Christianity for several hundred
years after the
you know the mission the time of the
mission of Jesus Christ but you know
it's related in the Bible the you know
the story of Lazarus that when Jesus by
the will of God raised it raised Lazarus
from the grave by the will of God
Lazarus came out walking and what
happened to the Jews who were there who
witnessed the miracle Wow what happened
they all became Christian right no no
half of them declared belief in Jesus
not in Christianity because again that
came after a couple hundred years no
part of them declared belief in Jesus
that that Jesus was a prophet of God and
the other part ran to the Romans and
said that this man Jesus was raising the
dead by the power of Satan
so some became believers some became
disbelievers and the Christians tell
this story you know basically saying how
how could they be so stupid as to deny
this theorem miracle in front of their
eyes and yet at the same time they
continue to do the same thing they see
the miracle
the miraculous nature of the Quran they
know the chain of Revelation and and by
the way in the Old Testament the Old
Testament predicted three prophets to
follow you've got John the Baptist you
have Jesus Christ where's the third you
read in the New Testament where the the
scholars of the Old Testament the the
priests and the Levites or excuse me the
rabbis in the Levites they came to John
the Baptist when he was preaching and
asked him this question they said you
know who are you are you Elijah
he said no are you the Christ he said no
are you that prophet he said no that's
one two three even in the New Testament
we have evidence that there were three
prophets predicted to follow so if you
take John the Baptist as one and Jesus
Christ as the second who is the third
who's the final prophet predicted in
both the old and new testaments to
follow so once again you know if you if
you're playing this game of criticizing
the Jews for not seeing the truth when
it was in front of their faces you can
you can also point this out to the
Christians who are telling that story
and saying yeah well where are you with
this you know I mean you should know if
you don't know you should know that your
own book speaks of a final prophet to
follow number one okay and then number
two you should embrace the evidence that
is clear in front of you just as clear
as if Lazarus came out walking and
embrace the final Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him but the way that these
things normally go they have no problems
denouncing the Jews but they refuse to
implicate themselves you guys keep
tuning in we'll bring you more salami